hello everybody
hi
all right so i see lisa and brad are in
the chat
that's wonderful sure there won't be
that many people
tonight because of the whole holidays
things
so i am in a seriously very slow
mood um yes
i see in the chat new house this is my
future office slash studio
for now it is an absolute insane crazy
mess with a bunch of stuff because
we my family and i went
nuts trying to just be in this house for
christmas
we worked like mad the last week that's
why you probably didn't see me much
online
but just not involved at all uh
trying to make it for christmas and we
did we were able to
uh put up the christmas tree on the 24th
and
wrap our presents and prepare everything
um
so yeah so we did it and then the last
few days has just been winding down with
the kids in the family
you know kind of taking in
this return to our house which is kind
of a new house because everything is
everything is different everything is
new
and so so it's pretty amazing i actually
feel like i'm on vacation because
it's it's just very odd to just be back
and feel home i really feel
like i'm back home which i haven't felt
like that in a quite a while
so it's pretty amazing so i'm pretty
excited i'm pretty excited to be back i
feel
tired and rested at the same time and uh
yeah i know so many people who
who will be watching this have been
involved you know have thought about my
family i've prayed for my family i have
you know send us their
their wishes and also even have helped
financially you know
quite a few people helped us out when
the flood first happened which really
kind of helped us get through those
first
those first months that were kind of
crazy and chaotic and uh
and helped us even to uh to to fix the
house and so
here we are all right guys so
this is the last q a of 2020 the
greatest
i'm not good at sarcasm the greatest
year
this year has just been so crazy i guess
i kind of said it would be crazy but i
can't get over how crazy it's been and
and i think the thing about it is that
it's going to get
worse and that 2021 is probably going to
be worse
in so many ways which is very annoying
and so uh and so
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens at least we get get through
we'll see what happens
next week or the next few weeks you know
with
uh the us political situation
with all the lockdowns we're in we're on
lockdown now
you know they locked everybody down for
christmas no one's allowed to visit
anybody
in theory and uh and so
yeah so it's it's just it's just a crazy
time
but we will do our q a and hopefully
it'll help us think of other things
so shane artisan says 2020 the dumpster
fire that keeps on giving joe scott yes
indeed the thing is that
at least if you if we had the sense that
it was gonna end
it would not be so bad but it doesn't
seem like it's gonna
end it seems like it's going to continue
so yeah all right
okay so um
all right so here we go we're gonna
start and hopefully everything will be
okay
and so like i said this is gonna be my
new studio i even
have a new camera which i'm not using
tonight because i'm not totally sure how
it works yet
i actually set up my computer this
morning and i kind of set everything up
because i had a i had a meeting this
morning i
i hadn't turned on my computer since
christmas so it's actually a good sign
it means that i
actually did get some rest and so and so
uh
hopefully this will be a nice spot
all right so i'm going to start with so
no questions on subscribe star
i've been kind of pointing people away
from subscribe sorry if you're if you're
on subscribe star
i you know it'd probably be better to
support me on paypal or through patreon
just because subscribe star has been odd
and
you know it's hard to understand how it
works it
nothing is clear in the way that it's
described and i
they keep telling me i'm supposed to get
so much money and then i get like half
or a third of it
and so it's just odd they wrote me an
email trying to explain it but it's just
still odd the way they're presenting so
i don't
yeah i mean i'm still gonna continue
there as long as some people you know
trust that platform but
um i don't think it's not it's not my
favorite i have to say
okay and so here we go i will start with
uh nico says to which saying do you pray
most often
except mary and so i think that would
probably be
a toss-up between
saint maximus the confessor and uh saint
christopher
obviously and so say maximus is my
patron it's actually my
it's actually my name my orthodox my
baptismal name is
is maximus or maxim in french i guess
you would say
and um and then say christopher that's
obvious if you watch my channel you know
that i'm very close to saint christopher
all right nomad in socks asks
um
so i've been trying to understand and
summarize the broad strokes the points
you have been making about ritual and
symbolism
can you tell me if i have this right
ritual is used to bring
those with knowledge down into feeling
thus motivating them into action
symbolism is used to bring knowledge
down to those who primarily feel thus
directing their emotions yeah i'm not
sure
that's not that's not really um so
ritual helps the thinker feel and
symbolism helps the feeler
think thank you for all you're doing
god shines for you uh i think it's it's
that's
probably not the best way at least
that's not the way that i would
phrase it i can kind of understand what
you're trying to do there
but symboliz ritual is mostly just
symbolism in action it's just
embodied symbolism and so
symbolism is just the way in which
multiplicity comes into
unity and then you can still see the
multiplicity in that unity
that's so there's a pattern by which
that happens
there's a hierarchy by which identities
manifest themselves
and that ends up being the symbolic
structure
the kind of image of everything that i
showed you
it it happened in a fractal way at every
level and then ritual
is enacted symbolism
and so it's it's there are some versions
of some aspects of reality which appear
to us more
condensed you could say so you can kind
of see or experience or participate in
the pattern in a
in a kind of more direct way or
a more concise way and uh and that's
usually what we'll call symbolism
and in terms of action then that's what
we'll call ritual
hope that makes sense nomad in socks
all right and so i'm happy to see that
neil degrade is there
as dirt poor robbins in the chat
marianne ool is there as well that's
cool i look i can pay attention to the
chat look at me
i'm getting better at this you know
probably because there's less people
there
it's not going as fast as it does
sometimes um
all right so bogdan asks
i finally got around to listening to
lord of spirits after hearing it
recommended all over the place thanks
for bringing it
bringing awareness to it it's been
blowing my mind
yeah the context the show provides makes
the old testament stories much more
understandable and gives them a great
depth particularly regarding
giganto maki and fallen spirits however
this context also makes it feel more
distance
more distant from the present time how
do we have conversations about these
ideas both with non-christians and
christians
who are not necessarily aware of this
context in a world
where the very existence of these
entities is considered laughable
i love your conversation with
rationality rules and adam friended and
they were i think
important steps toward answering this
question so i think that
a good way is to to see what i'm doing i
guess like what i'm doing this is what
i'm doing i
i kind of joke and say that if i if my
work if the the things that i'm doing
can make it so that when you listen to
the lord of spirits
uh podcast you understand what they're
talking about and it doesn't
just sound like science fiction or some
kind of fantasy novel
that it actually sounds like a
description of reality then i think i've
i've done what i need to do and so i you
know i think that i
i'm constantly trying to give examples
or
show the way that being manifest itself
in ways that are more immediate and more
easy to kind of grasp but then
ultimately that should lead you to
understanding
these ancient stories and to see how
they're really describing reality
you know but i was talking to father um
father andrew about this just a few days
ago because i'm going to be on one of
his podcasts
uh like a long form interview and uh i
was i was talking about how they really
tend to stay in the mythological mode
quite a bit
whereas i try to
bridge the mythological mode with the
kind of more modern
scientific way of thinking or i try to
be attentive to the way that
modern people think and try to help them
kind of bridge
into the mythological mode but obviously
the mythological
mode is more is better because it's
because it's actually something you can
you can be in like it's a story you can
be in um
and a lot of the things they're saying
really help like they're just so helpful
you know i keep coming back to this idea
that father
stephen father stephen keeps brought up
which i guess i should have realized
that before i didn't realize it is
the idea that the relationship between
the sons of god and women
in genesis is just it's a ritual
relationship that is that it's done
through secondary causes
that there are rituals that bring about
you know that embody these
these entities into the world through
kind of sexual
relations like ritualized sexual
relations and
it's like i can't believe i didn't ever
thought that that's what he was talking
about
i read the hammer of witches last year
for those who were on patreon you
probably
saw my video on that you know i i read
the hammered witches and in that that
they basically
say the same thing they say that there
is no possibility for a demon and a
human to have a relationship but it has
to happen through
secondary causes and some of those are
you know kind of these ritual
relationships they also mention other
secondary causes but
it has to happen through secondary
causes so anyways
so i'm really excited about about uh the
lord of spirits podcast everybody check
it out it's definitely worth
listening to um and it's just
the more they the more they go the more
they're able to kind of bridge you know
they say some wild stuff like th
they're really saying the things that i
wish i could have been saying quite a
while ago but that i
that i always like feel like i need to
prepare people and they just gotta dive
in
which is great for people who are ready
you know i think it's wonderful
um so timothy
aspelslaw says hey jonathan in the work
of art in the age of mechanical
reproduction
what does benjamin walter benjamin mean
when he states
the following fascism leads
logically to an aesthetization of
political life
which culminates in war communism
communism's reply is to politicize
art um yeah well
i think that benjamin is right when he
his opposition of communism and fascism
is quite
is quite right and uh i think that's
something that jordan
also really jordan peterson was really
able to to grasp on and to be able to
show how
they're really these two opposites that
manifested themselves
you know and so you can imagine that the
fascist tendency or the
the nationalist tendency is
to try to swallow politics up into
something like identity but then that
also ends up being something like
beauty in the sense of pattern right
and so you can imagine that the because
the
the fascists or the nazis especially
kind of obsessed with a
a manifest order and so you know the
idea of the you know
the giant the huge area filled with
people in
perfect squares and and this this this
kind of
idea of the procession you know this
this almost fetishization of the
of the military march and the procession
and all the pomp
that goes with you know that kind of
imagery
is something which was taken to to
really high
levels in the in fish in fascism so you
can understand why
for a fascist politics would be
would be kind of swallowed up into
identity and beauty
and uh you know and this kind of
aesthetization that he talks about
which is which is actually quite
superficial but nonetheless can
can have an effect on you whereas
benjamin benjamin i need to pronounce
his name right
benjamin is always showing how his
side which is the communist side he was
a communist is
always trying to destroy the patterns
he's always trying to use
mechanisms to destroy the
the the appearance of being you know
basically
you know and so for him all these things
like mechanical reproduction
you know mechanized culture was
a way to destroy a pattern and so
it so art became in
just another kind of political
a political tool which was used
especially with mechanical reproduction
so you can imagine propaganda you know
printed posters and and kind of this
mass
art that was uh that was available to
everybody
it was a way to take away the take away
the glow you know i talk about sometimes
the glow of something which is special
or that
you know this glow that you get when you
see the cup that your grandmother gave
you
that it has a layer on top of just the
just the regular cup
and so there's something about it which
makes it stand out and
that's what benjamin and the communists
were trying to destroy
um so
all right so tara thomas asks
would you consider token and or cs lewis
symbolic thinkers
if so why it's interesting i've been
thinking about that for some reason
recently i don't even know why
i've been thinking about it quite a bit
i think that i'm it took me a very long
time to really understand token
why token was so adverse to
saying that his work was allegorical
whereas c.s lewis's work is very
allegorical
and i think that it's actually because
tolkien is more
a symbolist in the sense that he talks
about how
he wants his stories to be applicable so
he he doesn't like the idea that his
story
represents something else but he likes
the idea that his stories can be applied
to situations
and i think that that's a great way to
understand symbolism
is that he's creating a story which is
patterned in the right way
so that then you can see analogies
in the world and so it actually it's
actually kind of like as if his story is
above
and then you can apply it to different
circumstances because it
it it manifests the pattern so well
whereas
whereas lewis seems to have been more on
the allegorical side
you know where i was going to say it's
like aslan is jesus you know but
in in uh in tokyo you don't have a
character that's like
this is jesus and i really want you to
know that it's jesus it's more
it's more a laid out pattern of
different of different
aspects of being which kind of manifest
themselves so
so i i actually in terms of storytelling
and in terms of patterning
i prefer toki
all right so david flores asked why did
the principalities of the greco-roman
myths continue to persist
in the naming of the planets moons etc
with our expansion of scientific
knowledge
well just because those are the names of
those things
you know the let's say the naming of the
planets the moons etc it's more than
greco-roman myths
you know the the planets have names that
are quite universal and that
have have caught you know are cognates
to
to each other you know and so the id you
know for example like if
if we have the notion that there's a
relationship between
god saturn and saturday you know
this type of relationship it's also
there in hebrew like
the name for the planet saturn is also
the name for
the sabbath and so it's it's these these
things are not arbitrary they
and they're not just greco-roman they're
really more ancient and more
pervasive than that and it's because
they actually are naming a pattern
that's there
that it really exists you know and maybe
especially in the kind of later
greco-roman culture that pattern seems
to have been
somewhat forgotten or twisted for
just whatever means but but at the
outset you can kind of see that it was
named the right pattern and so you just
can't avoid it you know they tried you
know it's hilarious
during the french revolution they tried
to do all this kind of stuff
where they tried to like rename the
months of the year and they tried to
like rename
remake a whole calendar and uh yeah it
didn't work
you know they're more they're a little
more people are a little more successful
now
um you know they always have the
international day of this or that which
they
they mention like they'll mention it on
the radio or something but nobody really
celebrates international this or they
this or that day not
like we celebrate christmas or celebrate
easter or something like that
all right so
so marianne says i must have missed the
part where he explains why we suddenly
have a diagonal view of the pedro
this is because i'm just not set up in
this space yet and so
i just set up my camera the way that it
could work in the space soon you will
have a much better setup and i actually
have a much better camera
i actually i saw i saw that paul vander
clay all of a sudden
had such a better image of him and i
became very jealous of paul vander clay
and so i tried to listen to what tried
to figure out i listened to his videos
and then i
heard him mention what camera he has and
then i bought the same camera
uh you know like during the during the
like pre-boxing day boxing day that
everybody was doing
because all the stores are closed here
all right why am i talking about that
it's not important all right
okay so numa ash asks why was it
important for paul to circumcise timothy
well he basically says what was
important in scripture he says
it it was because of the of the jews
that were there and
saint paul one of the aspects you see in
saint paul is that he has this idea that
you can kind of
you can in the heart or in christ you
can transcend
the forms and so he seems to talk about
that all the time like he
he seems to talk about how you know this
idea that we know there's no longer
greek nor
you know roman or greek nor greek nor
june or man or woman in christ and that
as you move towards the source of all
things then you transcend
the the the forms like that the forms in
the sense of the the particulars
and so this is why he talks about this
idea of the circumcision of the heart
which is
ultimately what even physical
circumcision is supposed to be about
it's pointing towards this idea of of
the circumcision of the heart which is
you know this move where you you know
you move towards the middle and your a
kind of remove the buffer
the peripheries um and so but at the
same time he doesn't
he also acknowledges the importance of
those things like he
he has this idea that they continue to
kind of exist
um which is why he also tells you know
how men and women should interact and
he talks to he talks to people in their
own
and he also is a chameleon where he is
you know roman to the roman greek to the
greeks and all that stuff
um and i think that he
like he does he didn't feel the need to
scandalize the people who were there
by by not performing the ritual which
was recognized
by them at the time so i think that's
why he did it he just
he just felt like it was not that it was
not
the purpose isn't to scandalize people
and i think this is
it's actually probably a good lesson for
a lot of people it's like
if you know if you know
if you have access to something higher
you have access to like a higher
aspect of the world or
it doesn't mean that you go around you
know debunking
the what the the the lower aspects of
these things
you know you should rather try to fill
them with meaning and stuff and so
so there's you can know you can you can
actually recognize a charlatan when they
go around
telling people that they that they
understand the higher mysteries and that
they're kind of above everything and
they don't have to follow any of these
these little rules and these little
things because they've reached higher
levels
like you can smell it you can smell it
charlatan when someone says something
like that you see a lot of that in the
kind of the weird you know spiritual not
religious folks
all right so josh the mover says i've
heard it said before
so i've heard it said that before the
second coming of our lord a new elijah
will come
as john the foreigner preceded the
incarnation
is this a dog with the orthodox church
of your speculation
how do we distinguish such a figure from
a false prophet
and so there's this idea in
revelation of the witnesses and so there
are different traditions about how
these witnesses are
you know um elijah and uh and
enoch this idea of these these people
who kind of ascended into heaven
and now kind of come down and and act as
witnesses
you know there's you see that in uh in
revelation and
in some of the early traditions so there
is
kind of this idea and i mean it's not
that hard to
to distinguish it's not that hard it
might be harder than you think but
you know way to to distinguish
a false prophet from a real prophet one
of the ways is that
the the prophet is calling on on someone
else like the the prophet
is preparing the way you know saying
john the foreigner was
preparing the way for someone who is
greater than he was
and so so he wasn't trying to
wasn't he didn't want the buck to stop
at him he wasn't calling upon people to
worship him
or to to you know admire him he was
constantly trying to
even though he did have disciples he was
constantly trying to kind of
show people the way towards something
else
um and so you know it's like
if someone appears and wants to start
their own church
then that's already a big problem but if
someone appears and is
telling people that they they should go
back to church or that they should
rediscover
the the tradition that they should
return that he should repent the way
that
saint john talked about then already
you're in a safer spot i think
anybody who starts their own church is
already i'm sorry it's is
is just right away is a problem because
authority doesn't come from you you
can't you can't
self your authority never comes from
yourself
it always has to come from from someone
else
you know and so even christ for example
whose authority came
directly from god for the people
manifested it as being baptized
by uh john the foreigner and and john
showing everybody that this was the one
that he was preparing to wait for
and so this is this is just how it
should be you know and so
i always kind of joke and say that like
i i agree with martin luther when he's
criticizing the
corruption of the church and the kind of
the abuse of the
of the uh the system of indulgences all
of that i'm like i'm with you
luther i'm with you and then when luther
starts to like name his own priests
and starts to act as if he's this bishop
all of a sudden
then it's like sorry mr luther then i
just can't
follow you anymore same with a lot of
the other reformers it's like as soon as
you
take authority on yourself and you start
to have your own church
then and it seems to me
like you're on the wrong track
so adam asked hi jonathan i saved your
spirited away video until i could get my
hands on it i watch it along
with your analysis last month and i'm
going through all the miyazaki's movies
with my wife
are there any other miyazaki movies that
stand out to you symbolically
yeah i mean i would say all of
miyazaki's movies are
wonderful in terms of of symbolism
but i think spirited away is definitely
my favorite but you know
house moving castles is wonderful um
what is it the castle in the sky that's
also is that the city in the sky or the
castle in the sky
that's really wonderful um
also ponyo's great they're just they're
just all really great
he just has such a uh just has such a
powerful symbol
symbolic intuition
all right so mikhail asks what is the
relation between logos and logic
and mathematics that is an extension of
logic really
is math and ultimate language of angels
a prime minister of angels there are
even all those sunday school paradoxes
about
god being almighty but unable to break
logic and so
uh there's definitely a relationship
between
logos and logic that's for sure but
i would say the one thing that
differentiates logos at least
in the christian sense and this is i
think one of the
the powerful keys that christianity has
offered but not only offered but also
i would say embodied maybe because you
could probably see it a little bit in
the
in your plateness that it's embodied in
it that is really useful for us right
now and
as we see where the sciences are and the
questions of relevance realization
and of emanation all these questions and
of uh of
uh that emanation but with the word
man my mind i hate when my brain does
that um
anyways uh the the idea is the
difference between just
logic and the way we think of it and and
logos is that
logos also includes the reason
like not reason in the sense of of of
logic but reason in the sense of purpose
like the reason for something the the
why the why of it
and so it's not just that it shows the
order of it but it shows that the order
of something
is is bound up
in the very reason why it exists so
the reason why it appears to us as
something and not just a bunch of stuff
you know and so so therefore the logos
has
the logos becomes the origin of
something that is
it's the reason why it even comes out of
the void of the multiplicity right and
so
there's there's there's indefinite
possibilities so out of that
comes something and so there's a reason
why it comes out
that reason shows us the order of the
thing
but then it also shows us the purpose
in the sense of the end of it too what
is it what is it moving towards like
what is it what is it aimed at you know
and so um
it's easier when we think of things that
are directly directly related to that
like if you think of a
like a tool like a hammer right the
hammer the reason for the hammer
it's also its aim it's also the purpose
for which it it
it it exists but that's actually true of
everything it's just
harder sometimes to to see it when it's
not something that is made by humans but
nonetheless all the categories that
appear to us
appear to us as um as categories of
meaning to us
i think jordan jordan peterson talked
about this quite a bit he talked about
how even
when you look at a chair
or even if you look at a certain shape
of rock you you actually see
like that's a place to sit on or if you
see an object of a certain size you
you see it as this is an object i can
grab it there's something about the way
the world
manifests itself to us which is always
purpose-laden
you know at the first level and so we
need to this is more
related to the idea of logos in the
christian sense
all right so phil asked is there a
parallel between the first sunday of
advents this year november 29th reading
of mark
13 33-37 where jesus warns the disciples
beware keep alert for you do not know
when the time will come
and santa claus is coming at night
discreetly
staying awake might mean santa will pass
your house without stopping
of course but the idea that someone
might come by
by when you're being inattentive or
asleep is interesting
um yes i think there's definitely a
relationship it's not a direct
relationship
but there's definitely a parallel
relationship
uh the one of the things that
that that santa coming down the chimney
uh during the night when you're sleeping
has to do with
it has to do with the incarnation quite
a bit
you know in the sense that that's what
happened you know the
so christ comes down you imag i mean
obviously that's not what happened but
if you look at the icon for example you
can see it's like there's a star
and then down from that star in the cave
is the christ child which appears hidden
you know to most and you know and so is
this hidden gift which is there
in the in the cave that is at the bottom
of the chimney right in the
in the darkest place where the animals
are and
and in the soot you could say and so the
the the manger is like this
is the bottom of the chimney right it's
it's the darkest place
and so that's where santa comes down and
then manifests himself in
in the darkest place so in the middle of
the night
but also in the middle of winter not in
the middle of the winter but at the
solstice right at the lowest day at the
lowest
moment when the sun is the lowest and so
this is what's going on in the story of
santa and coming down the chimney
all right okay so i think
i think we're done with the
website let's move on to to patreon
less questions because of because of
christmas
probably good i have more time to kind
of to check out the uh
check out the chat and engage with you
guys there
okay so here we go with the
patreon question so as you know i i
guess i should tell people
so guys you know people on patreon who
are supporting me at 10
or more get to ask questions in advance
and then after that then i i go in and i
look at
the super chats but if if we have less
questions today maybe i'll be able to
kind of pick some stuff
out of the chat i kind of i always hope
that i can do that
but it just always ends up being like an
hour and a half or two hours and then
i'm
i'm out of steam anyways by the end so
um
so christopher juarez says
um i missed the advanced sales from your
carvings you posted the information on
youtube but i realized too late that the
icons themselves
were only on twitter would you consider
notifying patrons by
email next time i really want to
purchase a card from you thank you for
everyone
so so for those who don't know i have
two
patreon projects one which is related to
these videos and is related to the q a
and also to the monthly kind of patreon
video that i make for
for patrons and i also have a patreon
project which is related
to my carvings and then people support
me there they get
access to uh prints and to drawings
and to early access to these carvings
and so i'm that's probably still how i'm
gonna do it and so those carvings i put
up actually
on the my carvings patreon at first
and a lot of them went there and then
when i ended up putting them up
online then they went super fast in like
one day
and i usually put up carvings they go up
super fast
and so i mean we'll see
maybe i could consider having people on
the video patreon like
have some advance notice from just the
general public that might be a good idea
i could do that
i could do that uh maybe i'll consider
that so get re if you what guys wanna
i'm gonna have another sale of these
types of carvings these
kind of ornamental carvings with uh
mosaics and some gilding maybe and stuff
like that
uh i'm gonna have those at uh just
before pasca
and so these these projects are done
with with my assistant
who is helping me kind of develop new
styles and new
new um new designs and he researches
different ornamental patterns and we
kind of look at it together
you know i kind of recarve some of the
parts and we worked on them together
which is what
i'm able to kind of get so many done you
know in
as a batch and so just before easter i'm
probably going to put out
another maybe 20 of these so get ready
for that
so walrus king 14. hi john and
jonathan do you plan to continue your
series on video game symbolism
i know 2020 has been crazy and that
first tomorrow video wasn't a big
success
but i hope you choose to continue on
with it maybe a video on the first zelda
game eventually
i appreciate the energy it's interesting
because it is true that it's because
i was kind of super i was kind of
disappointed
that um that the video didn't get more
views i thought come on people
been asking to do video game symbolism
for a very long time
but you know it's possible that no one
cares about donkey kong and doesn't want
a
a video game interpretation of donkey
kong
so i probably will make the the
mario brothers video see how that goes
and if that goes well then maybe
i'll do some other video game symbolism
but no promises because i don't know
we'll see
so jesse blamey says
i've begun to get a sense that the
western church has over time placed less
emphasis on the nativity
what more important what more important
to understand as the story of christ the
nativity or the crucifixion resurrection
are those two stories akin to the
symbolic dualism of heaven and earth
um there's definitely a relationship
between the the
nativity and the and pasca
easter for sure in the orthodox church
easter easter is always more
is always more important it's always
just a bigger feast it's the feast of
feasts you know it's not even considered
in like the 12 feasts of the year it's
like a
it's like a feast of feasts and so
so it's definitely has more prominence
but i think that the nativity is super
important
actually i i kind of felt the opposite i
felt like the west
emphasizes nativity more like christmas
is a way bigger deal
here um and it's it is a bigger deal it
seems in
than easter here but i think there are
there
obviously some parallels you can watch
my video on uh
on the nativity i did a video called i
think it's called uh
christmas as the foundation of reality
some
some some title like that which i always
use uh nativity as the foundation of
reality or something like that where i
talk about
how you know the the structure of the
nativity icon and the story
and how it also relates to uh how the
the the cave and the womb of the mother
of god
also functions as the tomb and you know
christ that is wrapped in
in linen it is wrapped in swaddling
clothes
is meant to resemble christ to his wrath
for his death and the manger becomes the
his coffin and so there is like this
parallel which which
appears for sure
um and there's also something about how
in you know one of the versions one of
the versions of scripture says that
there were two angels in the tomb i hope
i'm not mistaken here
and one was that the feet and one was at
the head of christ
so this is related also to the ass of
the ox which is
in the nativity scene and it is also
related to the two cherubim on the
on the uh ark of the covenant so so
those two angels are actually
the two cherubs you know on the ark and
and the
christ's body and the tomb of christ
becomes the ark
becomes the space where the the divine
revealed itself
um all right
so daniel demarco says hi jonathan i
hope you and your family are getting
settled into your home and that the move
went well
what is the meaning of genesis 15 9 11
when abraham sacrifices the heifer goat
ram dove and young pigeon
then drives away the birds of prey i
think it has something to do with
multiplicity
duality and unity wow you got me there
because i don't remember that
it's rare that there's something from
genesis that i don't remember
cut them into
so the lord said in bringing a heifer go
to ram each
three years old along with a dove and a
young pigeon is this
this is actually not is it the sacrifice
or is this when
god is this when he makes the covenant
and cuts the
cuts them in two
um
yeah this is this is actually not it's
not it's not that it's a sacrifice
this is actually the covenant that god
makes with with abraham where he
where he separates the animals into two
and then
then kind of god kind of comes through
the middle
of these two opposites you know and you
can understand that as
these two opposites that i'm always
talking about right left all of this
you know um and it seems like
this the the chasing away the birds of
prey
probably has something to do with this
let's say a refusal of idolatry
in the sense that the birds are
the spiritual represent the spiritual
beings you know they fly up in the sky
they're flying the heavens and so
i've talked about how the bird of prey
represents the manner in which some of
these principalities
can let's say take up
things you know they can suck up things
into themselves you know i've explained
how uh prophet samuel talks about
how you know he talks about the downside
of having a king which is the king if
you have a king then the king will come
in and we'll take things from you and
we'll kind of bring them up into him
and so we'll take the best of you we'll
take your best women we'll take your
best men
and uh we'll kind of pick that away and
that's what the bird of prey does right
the bird of prey
comes down and then takes the flesh and
then pulls it up
you know um and so i think that that's
what's going on here is that is that
abraham is chasing away
the false gods or the small
principalities so that he can be
in communion with the the god of heaven
or the creator god
at least that's what it seems to me that
what that's what's going on
all right and so keenan wang says
in the orthodox symbol of faith we say
that christ was crucified
for our sins is this understanding on
the right track we create
death through sin and in order to
conquer death
he had to die yes
and so the orthodox understanding is
mostly
the idea of the filling up right and so
christ in his incarnation had to kind of
fill the different aspects of reality
to kind of to manifest them if you read
um
saint john chrysostom's wonderful homily
for
uh for nativity he kind of talks about
that how christ became this
for he talks about different categories
of human
human beings he talks about you know the
the prostitute the publican you know the
the shepherds the kings the all of these
different aspects of reality
and how christ kind of fills those
aspects you know let's say manifest his
glory in those aspects
and so that goes all the way down into
the grave where
christ fills death even with his with
his
his glory and so that's the idea so he
died for our sins
in the sense like you said that as you
miss the mark so imagine you have a
bull's-eye you miss the mark
and so you move away from the center
you're moving into fragmentation
into multiplicity into this breakdown
and so
christ actually goes all the way to the
edge
and kind of brings it all in and fills
that with himself
and shows you know i always kind of i
always tell you guys that christianity
is a non-dual
religion and that's one of the aspects
of the death of christ
is to manifest the the
how god transcends duality
so drew mcmahon asks is there a
distinction between mind and soul
perhaps somewhat related between
thoughts and prayer
i mean those words are messed up it's
just hard to know what it is that people
refer to
and so it's really difficult so that's
good way to
if you read the church father especially
the ascetic fathers
if you read the philocalia for example
you'll see that
in the in the text there is this
three-tier system where you have
something like
the noose which would be the intellect
the highest aspect of you right the way
in which you can
grasp immediately directly you know
god and not just god but also the the
the logos in the world and so you can
grasp the patterns directly
and so then under that you have what you
would call
soul or you know something like
more like your psyche which would be all
your thoughts all your feelings all the
non-physical aspects of you which are
are less direct let's say and also which
are
more related to the body in the sense
that you know your
your thoughts and your feelings will
will um
let's say will affect your body right
you know how do you
although your feelings are not physical
you you you experience them
in your body in certain places so um so
i would say that that's
probably the best way to understand it
so duratia asked are the pentecostal
charismatic churches and movements on
the edge of the church
they have all these phenomena like
singing dancing screaming for imitation
on one side
but also mega churches on the other i
also experienced some weird view
where you had to be a charismatic to be
a real christian i don't know if you
could call that a pathology of the edge
but maybe that is my experience and
isn't
present everywhere anyway i like to hear
your thoughts
i do actually think that i i really do
see christianity as a hierarchy
and i've talked about this before i do
see that
like i don't want to justify some of the
weird aspects of
you know charismatic movements and stuff
but i i nonetheless see that they have a
reach
and a kind of a kind of uh
appeal to people who need more
sensuality
you could say you know sensuality in the
sense of uh you know kind of
extreme experiences and all that stuff
and so so i don't want to justify it but
i
nonetheless see that it has something
and there is something
like i always joke no don't joke about
it but i always talk to you guys about
how there is this strange connection
between
the bottom and the top and so there's
something about
death and glory this this flip that
happens and i think that
there's something about the charismatic
movement which is
always on the verge of becoming orthodox
like it
it's like it's it's really it's really
on the edge and it has all this chaos in
it
but there's something about the mind of
a charismatic person
which is more capable of understanding
symbolism
than a um than a kind of
high church super rigorous you know
type of uh a protestant let's say
um and that's just an intuition that i
have and i've noticed that like i've
read
some a few charismatic kind of prophetic
texts
and you'd be surprised sometimes how how
they get it right
you know and so so sometimes it seems
like they get
some of the pattern right they get the
they can see it
uh it's just that it's disordered and
they don't necessarily have the fullness
of
seeing how it connects to everything and
how you know you
you if you have a vision of a sacred
mountain with like
you know with heaven with a paradise
above and i've seen these charismatics
you've had these visions and
it's like you know maybe your church
should be shaped that way maybe
you know maybe the way you pray should
have that
pattern too you know if that's what
you're seeing in your visions but
anyway so that's my that's my intuition
about that
all right so sander tudor says
given that as humans we evolved to live
in symbiosis with other organisms like
bacteria why shouldn't we negotiate
rather than reject peace with artificial
life um
i i don't think i've ever said that we
have to reject
artificial let's say artificial life or
artificial
intelligence it's the problem is always
the it's always place it's always like
where
where is the the place of things and so
one of the difficulty with artificial
life or artificial intelligence is
that we idol we we're idolizing it is
that we are
wanting to make these tools
into the very thing that rules us
and so you you that doesn't work
and it and if you try to do that then
these tools these mechanistic tools or
these
these empty shells are going to become
vehicles for fallen principalities
that's what they used to do they make a
body for the idol you make an idol and
then
the idol comes down the the god comes
and manifests himself in the idol
so there's something about and so it's
not that it's not that
the idea for example that the the in the
scripture there are no graven images
it's not true there are graven images
right you have the cherubim in the
temple you have the bulls in the temple
that you know hold the lava
you have different figures in the in the
temple you have different things
it's just that those weren't
they were in their right place they
weren't they were supporting
the seat let's say something like that
and so this is this is
the thing with this is the problem with
like facebook and google
and all these algorithms is that we
think they're going to
to to solve our problems we think
they're going to give us a solution
to the problem of meaning and they can't
and if we try to make them give us the
solution to the problem of meaning
then that's when you create a body for
for a for a for for all of your passions
to
kind of come together blindly and to
become
you know a very strange being that will
not be
not be the one that won't want
the best for all of us let's say
all right so nina mora says merry
christmas jonathan we talk about your
ideas a lot in our family
thank you for showing us well thank you
nina i appreciate it i really appreciate
it
i know i always keep repeating this but
i don't answer
a lot of the messages that i'm getting
because i just get too many
and i i have to be able to prioritize my
time or else
and go crazy but i really do appreciate
it i gotten several messages
even around christmas time of people you
know just kind of
expressing their they're you know
expressing their appreciation for what
i'm doing
and uh and telling me their story of of
their own personal transformation and it
always touches me
very deeply uh even if i don't answer
so thank you for those stories people
all right the wakeful says
uh dear jonathan if we should approach
christianity as
it did not entail an afterlife how
should we interpret scripture like the
story of the rich man and lazarus
luke 16 19 31 this passage seems to
clearly
delineate a life after death for
instance abraham says
to the rich man as he is being tormented
but abraham said son
remember that thou in that lifetime
received good things and likewise
lazarus evil things but now he's
comforted and thou are tormented
and so um so i don't know
why you say if we should approach
christianity as it did not entail an
afterlife i don't like afterlife i don't
know what that even i don't know what
that means like
you have a being and you have an
existence and that existence
ranges and has a has a range which goes
beyond your physical body it already has
that
it's like the fact that you can even
interact with me through youtube
means that my existence definitely has a
range beyond
just my physical body you know how could
i write a letter to you
and you answer me if we we if our
existence wasn't just if our existence
was just limited to our
immediate physical bodies and so we have
we have an existence which is
more than that and and we have there's a
way in which we have a totality of our
existence which
spans more than just your physical body
so i don't i don't have a problem with
the idea
of
like i don't like the word afterlife but
but the idea that being is not limited
to your body
like your physical body now that's for
sure i don't i don't i don't
i don't think that but you know it's
it's clear that
what when if you read that story it's
clear that
it's also not just a simple continuation
of
of existence the way that people want to
you know
understand it in like the movie ghost or
something like something as silly as
that because
it's like okay so abraham is so lazarus
is in the bosom of abraham so try to
figure that one out like in terms of
trying to understand it is just a simple
description of uh
of uh it's like he's in the bosom of
abraham
and and and and here is the the rich man
looking at lazarus in the bosom of
abraham
so obviously we're describing something
else something else going on
besides just a just a kind of simple
continuation of existence
after death right there's something more
going on and it's real it's there's
nothing it's not it's not fake it's not
imaginary it's real
but it's not just like uh you know it's
not just like what you see in
ghostbusters or some stupid thing like
that you know it's
it's something else all right hopefully
that makes sense
sometimes i'm wondering if i confuse you
guys more with my answers
than anything all right
so randall b says hi jonathan love your
discussion on marshall mcloone's work
there is a horror movie based on his
work video drone 1983
will you analyze its symbolism after
rewatching it i was shocked
by how accurate it is to mcluhan's idea
who made video drone i think i
i don't think i've seen it
all right it's made by david cronenberg
yeah yeah
um yeah i've seen a few of cronenberg's
work
in the past i i should probably watch it
i've never seen it i don't think i've
watched it
i will look into it as you notice i'm
not making a lot of movie
interpretations
these these days um
partly because i don't watch a lot of
movies but all right so chase and
lindsay asks hey jonathan i hope you and
your family had a nice christmas
at the end of this crazy year the
perfect year for christmas yeah
i was wondering if you had any insight
into the symbolism of spiders and why in
so many stories
they seem to be connected to the
feminine
well the reason why a spider would be
they don't wouldn't necessarily only be
a feminine
the reason why they're connected to
famine is because they because they're
associated with a web
you know they make a home they make a
they make a matrix
you know and so this matrix is
you know is like a lattice
in which things will come and get stuck
and so uh it's a it's a
you know the the dream catchers the
dream catchers are actually a really
good
way to understand this this whole
symbolism of the web
and how the web the matrix
you know the web or the this underlying
latin pattern
of being will will catch
potential you know and so if you look at
a dream catcher
you'll see that it has kind of looks
like a spider web
and then there are little stones that
are caught in the web
and these stones are the dreams that get
caught right that are that are caught by
this thing and so it's a
it's a condensation of a potential into
a form
so you can imagine this web now with the
little stones in it
now think of it as a as a um
as a net that is put down into the water
and then
catches all the fish and pulls it up and
so
that's the net right that's the that's
the
this is this matrix underneath the world
and so this is related to
the feminine because it's like the home
it's like the structure around which
things happen
and so um and so it's
the spiders web the fishers net this
dreamcatcher stuff it's all talking
about the same
the same thing and then it is related to
the feminine because it's the frame
um all right
so so charles harrell says
hi jonathan merry christmas the
expression we are all children of god
has in my mind lately jesus was the son
of god but aren't we too
does this imply we have the ability to
be as jesus was the embodiment of the
divine logos
thank you for sharing your thoughts and
wisdom and have a happy new year
yes then that that's exactly what it
implies it implies that we
that we can participate in christ that
we can embody the divine logos to a
certain extent
that we can that we can be co-inheritors
this is how scripture talks about it
co-inheritors adoptive
adopted sons adopted children
all of this language is there to say
that we are meant to
to as much as possible become that and
not just embody but also
rule uh with christ this is something
that
you know if you want if you're listening
to the lord of spirits podcast
uh father andrew and father steven are
doing a wonderful job is
about talking about how the actual
purpose of
one of the purposes of humans in the
world is to actually become
principles to become principles of
things and to and
and that they manifest their being in
the world in a way that glorifies god
not in the way that
that is just stops at them but in a way
that kind of participates in this grand
dance of multiplicity and unity and so
that's why we have patron saints of
cities and patrons
patron saints of different aspects of
reality because these
in christ these saints have actually
ascended
and have become the princes
the principalities of different aspects
of reality and that is what we're called
to do that is how we are called to rule
with christ um and so it's very
mysterious
it's very mysterious and so in a way we
are called to become like gods like
that's what
that's the purpose of of of humans is to
become
like gods not for our own sake but
in service to the most high then we just
kind of take our place in this
this massive hierarchy of beings that
act as principles for that which is
lower
than where they are so
that's how i see it
all right so christopher mihaly says
not quite a question i will read it
later than christopher
um so jacobus
raudanes what are the examples and your
own thoughts on
a possibility of physical violent
counter resistance response for
christian to the
cancellation of the center or hierarchy
itself
does christianity offer an argument for
a violent response
or is it a case of too much mental
gymnastics to constitute
a courageous physical defense i find
myself among christians who assume that
there is no need for a physical reaction
to evil
even if it's in their communities they
seem to take jesus
jesus story and become absolute
pacifists
this is in lithuania eastern europe
post-soviet bloc
it's as if the christian identity is too
weak to counter attack
um
i think it is possible man this is going
to be tough one you guys
this is going to be a tough answer for
you guys um
i think it is possible for christians to
in service of a higher purpose
to defend you know their home or their
territory
so i believe that the idea of the
christian knight
who fights for a higher king
someone who is above them fights
in the name of something above him and
then
in service to those who are below can't
defend themselves i think that it's
possible
now what's happening now is different
and what's happening now looks way more
like the story of
the the betrayal of christ by judas
and how from within
the west from within the christian story
rose up a traitor who
was a antichrist
and who then this
dislodged just deconstructed you know
brought about a dying of the church
and so i don't think that in that case
we should defend ourselves violently
in the same way that christ didn't and i
think
that it's not
there's a mystery there's a mystery in
dying i don't know what to tell you
there's a mystery in dying
there's a mystery in the martyr and
there's a mystery in what's happening
right now
and the mystery of the martyr is the
same mystery that is we're seeing happen
so as we watch christianity wayne and as
we watch it die
we have the responsibility to be seeds
for the resurrection rather than
fight off because how what are you gonna
fight off it's all coming from the
inside
it's like this weird rot that is kind of
manifesting itself from within our
country from within our churches from
within
our own traditions and so it's like it's
not the same
you know it's not the same as so through
that then there also
are attacks from the outside which are
happening i have to admit that
but there's mostly it's mostly this kind
of
this this strange betrayal from the
inside so
that's how i see it but i also i also
have sympathy for someone who would
disagree with me
and uh and uh i have sympathy for that
as well
so jl asks
is there a connection between how we
write and the way we think i mean could
a culture that uses
logo graphs to represent words rather
than a specialized system
of describing each sound think more
symbolically
to me an alphabet seems like scattering
fracturing there and say iconoclasm i
know ancients in the west
had always used an alphabet but math
literacy is only a new thing
and being facetious but to an extent
but to an extent but could really could
be
ready to uh could the ready adoption of
emojis reflect their return to symbolic
thinking
let's take it talking about symbolism
prozagly
being a necessary side effect of the
fragmented
tending towards a new unity this is this
is an interesting idea and i think that
your
your basic intuition is right because
ancient language were more idiogrammic
or were more
you know images you know even ancient
hebrew
the early hebrew letters were were uh
were more like hieroglyphs they actually
represented images
and were very simplified into forms
and it's it's it's really it's really
when
after the bronze age when
the west lost the the greeks especially
you know and and uh and the romans lost
their alphabet
and they retook a
a phoenician alphabet or actually a
semitic alphabet and so our alphabet is
semitic our alphabet is
is based on the same alphabet that
hebrew has but it's just that
it's a kind of weird like you said a
kind of weird fragmenting scattering
because it's
it's not it's there's no more direct
relationship between
the letters their meaning and it's
it's just phonetic right and so and so
it actually shows a kind of descent a
kind of fall
in the world um
but it also means more power and so it's
like that's what happens when things go
down is that
they lose their higher identities but
they also
have more reach and more power and so
that's also one of the mysteries of
christianity is that it was
supposed to go to the edge of the world
so it wasn't going to be in hebrew it
was going to be in like
the most popular form of greek that's
why dante wrote in the most popular form
of
of italian is that christianity also
kind of comes down
and fills up the dark spaces you would
say
but i agree that there's something about
the breakdown of grammar
that's happening with texting and
there's something about the return of
things like emojis that
are maybe hinting in a very strange and
surprising way
to the possibility of more
yeah of a more direct connection between
the actual image and the meaning
and so can it maybe can foster symbolic
thinking
i never thought about emojis that way
but that's pretty awesome i'll keep
thinking
about that
so nick scott asks is there any
symbolism to talk
about with respect to superstitions
for example not putting a calendar up
early or a broken mirror causing bad
luck my
best guess with the mirror is that
there's a full cycle that happens
during the seven years of bad luck but
beyond that i'm not sure
thanks as always i always i've i've
talked about this before i think in a q
a
about how there's more to
superstition than we think uh
and it usually has to do with seeing
things in a different
way not seeing um
not seeing causality direct like a
mechanical causality of the cause of the
of the effect of the superstition but
you know
i mean like for example like if i never
heard of the superstition i'm saying not
putting
a calendar up early but you can
understand why that would actually be a
bad thing like
if you putting up a calendar early can
be
a problem like it can be a problem
because you're not
means that you are projecting yourself
into the future too much
you're not in the now um
the broken mirror seems more immediate
like it's more it's more immediate to
imagine that
if you if you're not careful of that
which holds your image
and you're not attentive to that thing
which reflects your image
you know there's something about the way
you act that if you if you break a
mirror if
you're the kind of person that will
break a mirror uh
then you're probably in trouble
in terms of it's not a direct thing it
doesn't mean that if you break a mirror
necessarily bad things can happen to you
but it's mostly understand it through
these secondary causes of understanding
that
that you need to be attentive and care
for the thing which
which shows you your shows you to you
like that reveals you to yourself so if
you break that
then you're gonna have a you can have a
bad cycle let's say
so so i would say that most superstition
is like that where if you look at it
carefully you
pay attention and you you you try to ask
yourself like why this would happen
you know then then you'll find that it's
usually not as stupid as we think
but we have to move away from mechanical
causality
all right so charlie longoria asked
hello jonathan can you expand on the
discussion you had with rationality
rules when the topic
of homosexuality came up my friends were
gay and a person very close to me
came out as non-binary i love these
people and would do anything for them
but they
would see me as being a christian as a
personal attack
and that i am participating in keeping
them from getting married and pursuing
happiness i feel like people are
confused about
the word sin that to sin means you will
burn in hell for all eternity yeah
i mean we all sin so uh i heard her read
somewhere
that in leviticus when it says man shall
not lay with other men that it's
actually referring to pedophilia
uh but i don't know how true that is
yeah it's probably not true um
so how can i navigate this social
pressure to say oh my sexuality is not a
sin um
p.s tell me too we need to do a q a with
you yeah you need him to do
it matthew is not going to you're not
going to see matthew's face on the move
on a video anytime soon if he if he does
i'll be very happy but
i have to say that those possibilities
seem to get thinner and thinner
uh so this is the kind of stuff that's
going to get me banned from youtube but
that's okay
we'll go down this line this whole idea
of sexuality is probably
the one of the best ways to understand
what sin
is it's really really one of the easiest
and
most immediate way to understand what
sit is and it's so
simple and easy that it's actually
somewhat
dirty like it's you guys are not going
to like it and this is going to be
not going to be for kids but
sexuality has a mark and it its mark
that the bullseye of sexuality is
a child right that's the bullseye of
sexuality
and everything
in kind of christian sexuality has to be
somewhat aimed in the general direction
of
the child because that's
the union of heaven and earth that's the
image of
god in the soul and that's also
the the actual way in which the world
continues to exist
when you hit the mark the world
continues to exist
and this is this is this is all sin is
like that
now
the sexual act itself is also
the same thing the sexual act itself is
also
a arrow hitting a mark
and that's why sodomy is viewed
as missing the mark you're missing the
mark
when you when you don't
when you're not in the right place i
don't know how to say it without
becoming explicit
but it's a it's just a it's just it's
just one of the most easiest way to
understand what sin is it just means
you know finishing in the wrong place
right that's what that's what sin is
it's always that and so sexuality is one
of the most
immediate representations of that not
representation but
embodiments of what is sin
and so so on the one hand you understand
that this is
how the world works is that there's
a reason for things and a purpose and if
you
hit the mark then there's life
and if you miss the mark then there are
different degrees
of death right uh
and
and also we need to also understand why
everybody also misses the mark and so
it's that's the key to me in my opinion
is to say
that it's not first of all it's not just
about homosexuality it's about
every form of sexuality which isn't
aimed
and aimed towards hitting that mark now
everybody falls from that like everybody
does
no one is completely in line with that
because that's just how we are and and
so to me that's the that's kind of like
the solution is to say
you know for he who he who who uh
has no sin cast the first stone um
but apart from that it's like the
pattern is still there and you you just
can't
it's very very uh direct and it's very
immediate and it's
and it's like you can talk around it but
it's one of the most immediate
expressions or you know manifestations
of what sin is
uh so i can't it's like i can't deny it
because i see it right in front of my
eyes like it
it's just so clear that i can't for
social pressure
say say something else so sorry guys
um and and like i said i think that what
you said is right like
it's not about not loving people who are
dealing with this it's not about
not caring for people who who who have
these desires or have these practices
just like i still love my neighbor who
is living with his girlfriend
isn't married and i still love you know
you know
i i i myself haven't had a child in
quite a while so i
probably i'm right there with the same
problem and so it's like it's not like
we don't
it has nothing to do with whether you
love the person or not or whether you
care for them or
or it's just about understanding the
pattern seeing what it is
recognizing it as the the model and then
knowing that we all
fall short of it you know that's all i
can say so enough about that
right so lisa don't make a clip out of
this because i just don't i i think it's
important but i don't think it's worth
getting banned on youtube for this you
know um
all right so here we go
so jay garcia says hi jonathan i hope i
can argue articulate this well
uh how do you see overwhelming cynicism
playing itself out
i see a knowledge crisis coming or
getting worse as our institutions
undermine themselves indeed governmental
scientific historical
economic and fragmented realities
breeding distrust
on the bright side i see phenomenology
and symbolism
still available to us but how do you
integrate the cynicism
which seems to be intrinsic to an
upside-down world
so that community and friendship are
preserved you know and i
you know i there's only one way to do
that and i i wish there was more but
it's really to be to be
a just person and to
to be someone who
fosters trust and someone who can be
trusted to do things you know and uh you
know i say that and i'm not saying
that's what i
am but i don't i don't see another
solution that it's like you need to be
that which you want the world to be and
so if you if you
keep your word and you you know you do
that
then i think that's the best we can do
and also like i said know that we all
also fall short of that at least i do
all right so our generation is dumb
says hello good sir i hope you're doing
well i read your brother's book and
unless i'm mistaken
it seems the two of you believe that
heaven is the realm of the abstract
similar to how plato
viewed the realm of forms am i off base
here
um because if that is the case i don't
see how we can ask the saints to
intercede for us
i've heard you dismiss the idea of
heaven as a sort of higher dimension
however if it does conscious entities
such as saints can really get around
that idea thank you
it's like uh so a good way to understand
it would be
it's not that it's abstract it's
non-manifest or
above manifestation um and
and it continues to happen it happens
fractally you know and so
it's not just that that which is above
is
is uh is abstract you know
but how can i say this
and so these this hierarchy is actually
not
a hierarchy of of just concepts it's
it's
actually a hierarchy of beings
and so it and so the way it works is
like i talked about just before
it it actually ends up being beings that
become
principles of things and so it
the way that the world shows itself is
not
at first and foremost through concepts
but through modes of being
and so these modes of being actually
have embodiments and some humans
will kind of rise up into that mode of
being and become
the the principle of something and so
it's not
it's not uh it's not just abstract in
the way that plato talks about
it's more it's it's more it's more like
an ancient cosmology of god than what
plato says it's more like
this hierarchy of angels than what plato
said although there's a connection plato
can help us understand this
and and there there are ways to talk
about it and i try to of course
to talk about it in a way that is more
immediate for people that
are struggling with that or find it
difficult to get there
but ultimately it ends up being a
hierarchy of beings like
a good way i always use the army as a
way for you to understand it it's like
the army exists with with purpose and so
there's a hierarchy of
of beings in the army and there is a
general
who is something like the head or the
principal
and then the general will give direction
and that direction will then come down
into the world
and then the army can act as a as a body
and can do something can accomplish
things and so that's
more the way the world works than just a
bunch of abstract
things that uh that that uh exist and
kind of concepts or
you know ideas the way that uh that
plato talks about the ideas
in saint maximus and and i think in
christianity
are bound up with purpose not just
abstract ideas not just forms in that
sense
anyways that's how i see it so ronnelle
canada says hey jonathan what would you
say is the orthodoxy on destiny
you think we have a puritan destiny or a
piece of the cosmos we're responsible
for upholding
or would you say that it's more of an
interplay between a purpose god has
given us
the actions we take on in life how might
the story of jacob wrestling
the angel relate to this
i mean i think that it i've talked about
this before
it's mostly about understanding freedom
somewhat differently
it's mostly understanding that true
freedom
comes in what you would say
accomplishing your destiny so it's not
that you want to free yourself from your
destiny
uh and in christianity your destiny is
to
become like christ to the extent that
you can to the extent that your limited
being can manifest
christ in the world that's your destiny
like that's what
that's the plan that god has for you and
so as you
embody that then you are free and
if you refuse to or if you hold on to
smaller
aspects of the world then you actually
are a slave
so it's not like in the greek world
where you're like a slave to your
destiny no matter what you do
you can't get rid of it it's mostly that
your destiny
is to become like god and
you're a slave when you refuse that or
when you
you attach yourself to lower lower
things
um all right so conor mitchell asks
so do you have a resource that
functioned as an hq for the symbolic
army
of where we can share not just analysis
of some other strategies and methods
uh by which they've been effectively
revived and recreated in our respective
lives and fields yes we have a
facebook group which is acting exactly
in that way
and it's not me i'm not the one running
it i'm actually not even a moderator on
the group it wasn't created by me
um but uh it is it is
the place where the the best discussion
is happening
and um and so you can check that out
it's not it's not an
open group you need to uh you need to
prove yourself to the moderators before
they let you in
but uh but it's there um it's called
it's called the the symbolic world in
the
zombie invasion is that the right i
always forget the actual name of it
it's called the symbolic world within
the zombie invasion and so
you can check that out um
all right so i think we have the last
question here
so vic sardis says why is judas always
shown right next to satan and art
depicting hell i once saw
one where judas is on the devil's lap
just like how a child
sits on his father's lap could that be a
representation of how on how evil is
distortion of everything pure
and good or does it mean something else
ps i just received the language of
creation can't wait to read it i'm happy
yeah you need to read that book uh
it has to i think it mostly comes from
uh
it comes in part from dante where dante
places
judas he doesn't place him on his lap
but he places him kind of being
um being devoured by satan
you know like kind of in the bowels of
satan and so it has to do with
the idea of betrayal as being the
highest
sin and uh and so
so that's what it has to do with and the
idea of showing him
kind of sitting on the devil's lap the
way that
let's say christ would be sitting on the
lap of the mother of god is
is definitely meant to show this
parallel or
or uh opposition that there's it's a
really ancient tradition of showing a
kind of
parallel opposition between judas and
christ one of the earliest crucifixions
we have
will shows christ on the cross and judas
hanging from a tree and so both are
hanging from a tree but
one to his glory and one to his to his
condemnation
and so so it's a there's a really
ancient tradition of
of making those comparisons
all right all right so
so all right so since we have time i've
actually reloaded the page i usually
don't do that because i don't like when
people
write in their questions right when i'm
already answering but so christian
sakura asks um
hi jonathan sorry this is a bit long i
was walking through a christmas display
at my catholic college in houston and
saw
images of houston sports teams mixed
with christmas versions of pop
identities
from old trolls shows like charlie brown
or star wars i thought it was
interesting how the christmas identity
seemed
to be absorbed the pop identities and
direct their narrative to a more
christian one
it concerned me though that the secular
sports icon had no hint of christmas
identity
and seemed to be colonizing the
university rather than the other way
around
yeah how do you think we should approach
secular identities trying to take pieces
of the christmas story without christ or
is it just the beginning stages of the
invasion of christmas on the secular
world you know it can go both ways
and this is this is like if you want to
learn one lesson from my channel
is that you can turn the tide on this
pattern
for sure i would say and this is
definitely true
we have seen in the past 60 years or
maybe even more
we've seen a assault on christmas
like not that kind of assault that fox
news talks about like you know
but rather we've seen a desire to make
christmas as secular as possible which
is why if you listen to the radio you
can hear
christmas songs all day and not hear one
mention
of the birth of christ and you'll hear
about jingle bell rock and
whatever you know pop version of of
christmas you know and so
it's definitely a desire to reduce
christianity uh christmas to a secular
holiday
to reduce it to a kind of
aesthetic and feeling and all of this
and you know
it doesn't it just doesn't it doesn't
work like it it's gonna
last for a while but it can't last
because you know that's not how reality
functions
if something doesn't have a purpose at
some point it goes away
and so it's just gonna it's just gonna
start to degrade and degrade and degrade
you know and that's one of the reasons
why chris christmas has been reduced to
shopping basically
because part of the secularization of
christmas means that
you need a purpose for it and so in a
world that worships mammon
and worships money then shopping will
become
the reason for the season let's say um
but like i said i think there are ways
to flip it and if you watch my recent
video on
uh rudolph the red-nosed reindeer i
think you'll see
the ways in which we can probably flip
things back and surprise people
with some of their stories the the more
secular versions of chris
christmas and show how some of them end
up manifesting christmas
nonetheless and point back towards
christ not all of them
some of them are hopeless and will will
will be assigned to the fire
but a few i think can uh can participate
in uh the resurrection let's say it's
that way
um so kevin patterson says what is the
symbolism of nudity and where does it
fit in our lives eg with our spouse
family friends
of same gender so i've talked about this
a few times
uh you know nudity has to do
with a there are two nudities there's
one
nudity which is a nudity in the garden
and has to do with
revelation and a kind of of uh
of safety and and uh and
a capacity to not need the garments of
skin
right and so you can understand
that ultimately you would hope that
that's what
the relationship between a man and a
woman would end up becoming
you know and and you can understand it
the same like even just more immediately
it's like
when you feel safe at home
that's when you feel safe enough to take
your clothes off like you know you you
don't
change outside in public you have to be
somewhere where you feel
safe in order to remove your your
clothing
um and and so
then but then there's also a nudity
which is the new d of shame
which is the nudity of being exposed in
public and
and uh you know and let's say
not being able to contain yourself not
to being able to contain the secret
you know and so that is also part of uh
that is also part of um of the symbolism
of nudity
so all right guys i'm pretty much done
with the the questions and so i'm going
to go into super chat and see
what we got here
sorry not ready
[Music]
feeling slower than usual so
um
right
all right this is not what i'm looking
for
all right okay there sorry let's get the
wrong thing all right here we go
sorry about that okay and so
let's start with zach counts for five
dollars says i'm from the
southern united states and grew up
around southern baptist churches i would
love to know your thoughts on the
southern baptist tradition
and so i mean i i grew up conservative
baptist i guess you would call it
um and so i don't really know the
difference between the two
i'm not i would say that
i would say the the strength of baptist
is definitely their knowledge of
scripture and their kind of desire to
to really memorize bible verses and
and know all the stories you know i
think that's amazing and i think that
it's a
it's why i think
it's like my experience of kind of
discovering the church fathers and
finding
the kind of deeper mystery uh was based
on the fact that i knew the bible so
well because i grew up with it so i
really appreciate that but nonetheless i
feel like
like baptists are
not it's hard because it's such a big
denomination but i would say that a lot
of the batches that i've encountered
because they they've embraced
materialism without knowing it they've
embraced kind of materialism and
they've embraced a science they they
think science is
true just true like and so they
they get caught up in that stuff and
they they end up
you know they end up uh idolizing
science without knowing it and so
because of that they actually miss a lot
of the
patterns because they always try to see
the description
of what they see in scripture as a
description at the same level as
you know as some guy describing you know
the
the speed of a car or something so so
because of that they
some i felt like at least in my
experience that they struggled but
things have changed
so much and so i don't even know if
that's true anymore you know you look at
you look at a like i i've mentioned this
before like you look at the bible
project and this kind of protestant
uh reawakening of patterns and stuff and
you see it
in the theopolis institute and so it
seems like there are a lot of
more conservative protestants that are
right there like right
right at the door and there and are kind
of perceiving this so
so who knows what the future holds for
all of this
so brent retro mill for 999 says
mythology must live on
yes indeed it will no no doubt about it
um so patrick foley for 10
says armenianism calvinism and open
theism go
i don't have also symbology of the four
living creatures and the revelation if
you're interested
i'd rather talk about that like the
other stuff it's all
one it's all different versions of one
thing that happened you know the
all of all of the west
from the from let's say the late middle
ages from the end of the middle ages
until today is a
it's just this like break apart it's
like pulling a part of the incarnation
and
and a lot of the problems have to do
with that they have to do with
an incapacity to understand hierarchy
and capacity to understand how
uh how the word lays itself out in this
kind of beautiful pattern
and rather wanting to to radicalize
things and to see
it's like is it god's will or is it free
will and it can't be one
it's one it can't be the other and if
it's this kind of
uh you know this kind of battle which
just doesn't
need to be if you if you could just see
the world in this
as this this kind of flowing out you
know it just
a lot of this stuff is not uh so
um somalia the four living creatures in
revelation if you're
interested and so
i would i think that the four living
creatures definitely if my understanding
is that they're related to the four
faces of the cherub and the four aspects
of the divine chariot you know and so
they're also related to the four gospels
that's the way i understand the four
living creatures and so it just has to
do with
something which becomes four and so
these animal totems you would call them
i guess
manifest an aspect of the one
you know and so in really almost in
in the same way that when we talk about
how
your animal passions are below and you
know your being is above and
your animal passions pull you in
different directions it's actually the
same pattern
it's just in a positive way it's that
you have the unity of the one riding the
divine chariot
and then the four corners of the divine
chariot
manifest four different aspects
which appear as animals and so they're
the positive aspect of this multiplicity
you know um and so
that's the best way to understand it you
know i'm not gonna go into the specifics
of the different
uh faces but you know i probably talked
about that in other places
if not i probably should but it would
take too long to go into here
so gideon you for 999 says
i'm always very cautious about people
selling religion but you have described
patterns i know
but couldn't describe i'm looking into
orthodoxy this fear tradition is so bad
for us well
thanks for that story gideon i
appreciate it i'm happy to see
that i don't come off as a as just pros
proselytizing i hope not i'm sure it
happens sometimes but i really try not
to
i really it's funny because growing up
when i was young like they would ask us
to to go
door to door and like you know knock on
doors and tell them how jesus loved them
and
man that created such an aversion to
evangelism
in my in myself i always told myself i
would never evangelize
just hilarious because in a way i guess
it's like i'm kind of doing that
but i'm doing it in a way that i feel
good about because i feel like i'm
actually talking about reality
not trying to convince someone of some
arbitrary thing that they
need to believe to be saved or something
um
talking video games i am jesus christ is
coming out next year
i don't know what that sounds doesn't
sound good what's your take honey
telling the story of jesus in the form
of a first person video game
you mean that you're jesus that doesn't
sound right
that's not good that should not don't
play that game folks right man
mason bradford for five aud says thanks
jonathan
i watched a video recently in which
bishop baron said that learning a
foreign language
can be seen as a spiritual exercise
do you agree um that's an interesting
idea
it's an interesting idea in the sense
that it can definitely be
a very powerful exercise in
perceiving the limits of your thinking
and perceiving
how your your
category structure doesn't encompass all
of reality because you realize
like i know two languages very quite
like i'm
perfectly bilingual in french and
english um
and i are already for me it's such so
useful to notice that
there are actually some concepts which
don't exist in french and then some
concepts which don't exist in english
and so you realize how much
the how much language is related to the
manner in which things kind of
uh frame frame the world you know and so
i would say it it's i would for sure
suggest it to anybody to learn another
language
so chandler turner says to what degree
are dreams real
any thoughts on lucid dreams or
visionary experiences like swedenborg or
burm
um so the way that i like to
explain dreams or talk about dreams is
that
dreams are really kind of this descent
into chaos like
it really is like this going down into
the water
and so what happens is that
it's kind of like it is kind of like
something like divination like ancient
divination you know it's like this chaos
so you
but you throw the bones or you you know
you look into a pool of water or you
you know you you do something chaotic
you stir a pool
and you look into the pool and so that's
really what dreaming is so most of the
time it's just
a mesh of like nonsense but
it can also become the body
for a very high manifestation so it's
like
just like the chaotic waters
are that out of which god pulled out all
of the world
then the same thing can happen to dreams
is that
it's like once in a while
out of the out of this chaotic mess of
jumble of
images you know it's like god can
shoot a shoot a laser down and then
a very very powerful image can come out
of it
and that's why dreams can be prophetic
that's why dreams can be
visionary um but most of the time
they're not
most of the time they're just whatever
they're just not they're nonsense or
they're
they're you know i i
when you meet someone who talks about
their dreams too much like usually
there's something off like they're not
too
[Music]
it seems it can also be a form of
escapism and you need to be careful
about that
but nonetheless i think that that dreams
can be a place of visionary
experience and so um and yes i think
swedenborg and berm
definitely had some insight like they
definitely did have some insight
um it was kind of mixed inside i would
say but
uh definitely had some insight
so steven anderson for two dollars says
i love your take on
avatar the last airbender yeah i've
never watched that so
i don't know i i think i watched that
crappy movie that was made
of the of the the anime which was just
not good at all so that didn't help
um so leftistness for usd for attendance
he says can you speak on the tradition
symbolism or ortho burial sites
such as being returned to the earth the
40 day and when your anniversary
significance
why cremation is frowned upon um
yeah you know it's funny because i
really i know about the 40 days and i
know about
the whole process of uh after someone
dies in the orthodox tradition
and kind of the process but i don't know
it very well
because i don't know a lot of people
that have have died in the church and so
it's something that i need to look into
and i need to because i can
kind of perceive something there but i
don't really know much about it
um
cremation is frowned upon
that is there's something very intuitive
about that it's something about
the need to place the body down
in the earth and it returning to the
earth i think that that's really
important in terms of
understanding or let's say embodying
what the end of
life is you know and then also
in terms of community also kind of
embodying what this return to earth is
and you know it's it's a way to manifest
what it said in scripture
um and uh and i think that's probably
why
cremation is also frowned upon but some
of these traditions about
burial information and stuff are super
deep like they're
really really very
at very base levels and they're
difficult to understand
apart from a kind of superficial
understanding of them so
i probably don't have i'm not probably
not doing this question justice
um it's something i definitely want to
look into before i die
i hope or before someone i i
am very close to dies um
all right and so i have we got through
all this it is quarter to 11.
not bad i've been going like until 11
until now
so i'm kind of i'm actually scrolling
through the chat which i really do
it's just so hard to follow that all
right so i'm gonna what i'm gonna do
guys is i'm gonna
i'm going to wish everybody a happy new
year
i know that's strange to say that with
2021 coming
um i appreciate you know i appreciate
everything you guys afford me in terms
of
watching it's i i keep repeating myself
but i'm just so excited to watch
uh all these people kind of come up and
uh i see them in the chat derrick is
there
and i said uh you know neil degrade is
there
brad um all these people that are kind
of coming up and
christina was there in the chat marianne
lisa
um there's probably a lot more
but i'm just really excited to see
people
start to think symbolically and write
and and uh and i feel like uh
like there's hope and so i always keep
saying the future is
symbolic there's no way around that it's
happening you know the
the world is changing you know and i
think most people can feel it
and religion is coming back
and the world is going to be
re-enchanted whether we want it or not
and that's for all the good and all the
bad like the light and the dark
you know we're gonna see things in the
next few years which are going
to be unthinkable even now and uh
things are gonna get loopy and crazy
and we're gonna see things that we
haven't seen in thousands of years
are going to start to manifest
themselves and so
and so i'm just happy to see that there
that there's hopefully that we'll have
some people
who will have enough sense to
to be part of
part of bringing things to light and to
bringing light into things as well
so hopefully that doesn't sound
completely obscure to you guys
but um but uh yeah but get ready because
because because none of this is over
it's just starting
and uh and so so uh christ is born
and glorify him so i wish all of you
guys
a happy new year and a bit of time with
your family
to get some rest and get ready for the
madness which is
still on the horizon so bye everybody
i'll talk to you soon